nach zwei gewalttaten am späten
montagabend mit einem toten und einem
schwerverletzten niedersachsen hat die
polizei zwei tatverdächtige festgenommen
es deutet vieles darauf hin dass die
beiden taten nicht miteinander
zusammenhängen sagt ein polizeisprecher
am frühen dienstagmorgen hinweise auf
einen terroranschlag gibt es nicht die
polizei hat am montagabend einen 54
jährigen schwer verletzt in seiner
wohnung im bereich hamburger berg
gefunden
die beamten hatten zuvor einen notruf
erhalten nachdem es einen überfall mit
einem messer gegeben habe ein 51
jähriger der sich in demselben haus
aufgehalten hat wird festgenommen
es besteht nach dessen ersten aussagen
allerdings nur vager tatverdacht am
selben abend nur rund eine stunde später
wird der polizei zufolge ein 59 jähriger
im stadtteil neuenhäusen mit einem
messer schwer verletzt
der mann ist nach einer notoperation
außer lebensgefahr
laut seiner aussage hat ihn ein etwa 18
jähriger fahrradfahrer im vorbeifahren
mit einem messer verletzt nach hinweisen
hat die polizei in diesem fall einen 21
jährigen festgenommen
wir haben hier sehr viel zu tun jetzt
mit der spurensicherung mit der
vernehmung von zeugen mit der vernehmung
des tatverdächtigen
und natürlich müssen wir in erster linie
jetzt herausfinden inwieweit diese taten
miteinander in zusammenhang stehen
könnten
beide opfer und beide festgenommenen
sind laut polizei deutsche
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren